Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Die heißesten Talente Europas und im Weltfußball, ja, wo spielen die eigentlich und wer sind so die kommenden Spieler, auf die man blicken sollte? Diese Frage wollen wir beantworten in einem ganz besonderen Kurzpass. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ja, heute haben wir mal eine besondere Runde hier im Kurzpass, denn ich spreche nicht mit einem, nicht mit zwei, sondern gleich mit drei Gästen und warum, wieso, weshalb, das werden wir gleich erklären, nachdem ich sie alle der Reihe nach vorgestellt habe. Ich begrüße zum einen bei mir in der Leitung Sascha Felter auf Twitter der Ad Sascha Fültr, also quasi Felter ohne Vokale. Geht einfach auf rasenfunk.de. Ich habe es verlinkt. Servus Sascha. Außerdem mit dabei Marco Stein auf Twitter Ad Marco Stein unterstrich CF. Warum CF? Werden wir gleich klären. Servus Marco. Und per Telefon zugeschaltet ist quasi der Reporter unserer Außenwette, Henry Hina, ad Laserpass auf Twitter. Servus Mr. Laser. Hallo Henry. Wir haben schon ein bisschen Technik-Kickhack hinter uns, deswegen sind wir alle schon gut hier auf Stimmung gepolt. Jetzt ist die Frage, was vereint euch drei? Marco, wer seid ihr und was macht ihr?
Wir sind ein Fußball-Blog über internationalen Fußball. Wir sind mittlerweile rund 15 Autoren und schreiben dort über jegliche Themen im Fußball, hauptsächlich über Themen, die im deutschen Sprachraum eigentlich weniger Erwähnung finden. Also eigentlich Themen, die jetzt nicht zum Mainstream gehören. Dazu gehören auch unter anderem U20-Talente, die wir schon 2017 durchleuchtet haben. Und haben dieses große Projekt jetzt noch mal gestartet und sind gerade dabei, die ganzen Texte zu veröffentlichen.
Ein Blog mit über 15 Autoren. Und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, Marco, warst du einer von denjenigen, die von Anfang an mit dabei waren. Seit wann gibt es den kawanisfrisör.de?
Genau richtig. Also ich habe kawanisfrisör damals mit Alex Beelinger, der mittlerweile ja für Konzept Fußball und Spielverlagungen schreibt, gegründet, im Jahr 2013. Und damals zu viert angefangen, haben dann aber immer wieder Autoren verloren, dazugewonnen, Gasbeiträge bekommen und sind dann jetzt mittlerweile, nachdem wir jetzt im Sommer einen Aufruf gemacht haben, immer mehr geworden und haben unter anderem den Henry und weitere tolle Autoren bekommen. Und ja, so hat das Ganze eigentlich angefangen und mittlerweile ist es ein großes Herzensprojekt.
Ja, das kann man wohl sagen bei so vielen Autoren und dann auch bei dem Projekt, über das wir gleich näher sprechen wollen. Sag uns mal noch ganz kurz, bevor die anderen beiden sich auch noch kurz vorstellen dürfen. Marco, was machst du denn so beruflich bzw. was ist dein Bezug zum Fußball? Du musst uns jetzt nicht private Details verraten, keine Angst.
Ich wollte eigentlich immer Journalist werden und habe dann eigentlich durch den Blog viele Angebote bekommen. Ich war zum Beispiel während der EM 2016 ESPN-Korrespondent. Ich habe zusammen mit Sascha zum Beispiel für 11 Freunde geschrieben, auch für 90 Minuten. Mittlerweile bin ich eben durch den Blog zu einer Firma gekommen namens Better Collective und schreibe dort über jegliche Sportvorschauen. Also gute Empfehlung, wenn ihr z.B. wetten wollt.
Du weißt, dass wir von Sorenfreie hier sind.
Vorsichtig.
Es wird alles rausgeschnitten. Nein, bleibt natürlich drin. Der Rasenfunk ist ja ungeschnitten. Sascha, was ist denn dein Bezug zum Fußball und wie bist du dann zu Cavanis Friseur gekommen?
Zu Cavanis Friseur bin ich eigentlich gekommen. Das war –Marco, korrigier mich bitte –2015. Ich bin generell großgeworden in der ganzen Blockerszene von spielverlagerung.de, Konzeptfußball. Ich habe mich dann irgendwann mal selber daran versucht, am Schreiben, und bin dann recht zügig zu Cavanis Friseur gekommen. Seitdem schreibe ich eigentlich auch regelmäßig für Cavanis Friseur unter anderem. Ich mache beruflich etwas komplett anderes. Das ist gar nichts mit Schuralismus.
Das ist dein Hobby, sich dann auch mit Fußball zu beschäftigen und dann so viel Zeit in so einem Projekt zu stecken? Und dann haben wir noch unseren Telefonjoker, Henry. Wie bist du dazu gekommen und was machst du denn mit Bezug zu Fußball?
Ich bin auch mit der Blockerszene Spielverlagerung und Konzeptfußball großgeworden. Das hat so das Interesse bei mir am Fußball und vielleicht einen tieferen Blick im Fußball geweckt. Und dann hatte ich 2018 Marco auf der Seite, dann eben nach Bloggesucht. Da habe ich mich dann beworben und wurde zum Glück auch angenommen.
Da sieht man mal, das ist das schöne spielverlagerung.de. Spielt ja hier eine große Rolle im Rasenfunk. Und das ist jetzt quasi the next generation. Also diejenigen, die sich vorstellen und sagen, ja, ich bin mit spielverlagerung.de groß geworden und dann habe ich mein eigenes Ding gemacht. Das ist doch schön. So dreht sich die Fußballwelt immer weiter. Und jetzt habt ihr das Projekt 110 gestartet. Henry, du darfst mal mir erklären, um was geht es denn da?
Wir haben versucht, die 110 Top-Talente auf den Positionen jeweils, also immer die 10 Top-Talente, also 10 Torhüter, 10 Rechtsverteidiger, zusammenzustellen. Stichtag war der 1.1.1999. Und wir haben versucht, möglichst alle Ligen und alle Länder, alle Nationalitäten da reinzubekommen. Wir haben dafür eine Abstimmung gemacht unter den verschiedenen Autoren, welche Spieler wirklich dazugehören. Wir haben dann versucht, all diese 110 Spieler mit Texten zu beschenken.
Das stelle ich mir sehr aufwendig vor. Marco, wie seid ihr denn da vorgegangen beim Scouting und dann eben auch bei der Analyse der einzelnen Spieler?
Wir haben uns zuerst einmal hingesetzt und verschiedene Datenbanken sind wieder durchgegangen. Klassiker natürlich, Transfermarkt, und sind dort jegliche Marktwerte durchgegangen. Vor allem aber auch gibt es da die schöne Option, dass man nach Spielminuten und Spieleinsätzen filtern kann und haben da unter anderem viele junge Leute gefunden. Das Gleiche haben wir natürlich auch bei anderen Seiten gemacht. Und sind dann Texte durchgegangen wie die Guardian-List, wo immer wieder 16-Jährige dabei sind, die jetzt natürlich in unser U20-Projekt auch teilweise hineinfallen. Und haben dann das Ganze abgeglichen durch Statistikvergleiche über Insta und haben das Ganze dann auch noch live durch Spiele und verschiedene Einsätze kontrolliert. Und haben dann so eigentlich einen Pool von, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, über 550 Spielern gehabt. Und haben dann über mehrere Abstimmungen die jeweiligen 110 nach vielen Diskussionen herausgesondert.
Das hört sich nach einer Sache an, die man jetzt nicht an einem Wochenende macht. Sascha, wie lange wart ihr denn da so dran gesessen? Wann ging denn die Arbeit jetzt an der aktuellen Liste los?
Ich glaube, wir haben begonnen im September. Wir haben die erste grobe Liste veröffentlicht, bei uns intern in unserer Autoren-Community. Und sind dann, glaube ich, Ende Oktober in diese generelle Abstimmung gegangen. Alleine nur diese Auswahl von diesen Talenten ging knapp anderthalb Monate.
Kannst du jetzt mal für dich persönlich beziffern, wie viele Stunden du reingesteckt hast in Recherche, in das Ansehen von Spielen, wenn verfügbar, YouTube-Clips, Statistiken und so weiter?
Ich glaube, mehr als das, was ich mich stolz machen würde. Es war wirklich unnormal viel. Es gab schon manche Wochen, in denen man sich in Summe acht Stunden lang durch den Kitz gesetzt hat, und irgendwelche Datenbanken durchfostet hat, oder Clips auf Insta oder YouTube angeguckt hat, oder auf irgendwelchen russischen Streams sich, keine Ahnung, eine Ajax-Spieler angeguckt hat. Es war schon einiges, aber macht sie, wie gesagt, eigentlich was Spaßes und Freude, wenn man dafür irgendwas bekommt.
Marco, wie viel hast du reingesteckt an Zeit?
Unmengen. Ich glaube, der Sascha hat das schon sehr, sehr gut beschrieben. Ich habe bei der vorigen Ausgabe 2017 mitbekommen, es gibt dann immer noch ein Talent, das man nicht entdeckt hat. Das wechselt dann zwei Wochen später zu einem Top-Verein. Es wäre dann einfach zu schade, den nicht dabei zu haben. Deshalb haben wir es dieses Mal schon fast übertrieben. Ich möchte eigentlich gar nicht wissen, wie viele Stunden es waren.
Das hört sich nach sehr, sehr viel Aufwand an. Marco, wie war denn da dann die Trefferquote 2017? Im Nachhinein sind wir schlauer, wenn ich mir da die Liste angucke. Bei manchen Spielern nicke ich sofort und sage, ja logisch. War vielleicht auch damals schon zu sehen. Aber wie zufrieden bist du jetzt in der Rückschau mit der Liste von vor zwei Jahren?
Es ist eigentlich sehr interessant, weil es gibt ein paar Spieler, die, wie du sagst, sehr offensichtlich waren. Also in Onaruma, dass der scheitert, das wäre wirklich überraschend gewesen. Aber es gibt dann doch ein paar Spieler, wie zum Beispiel ein Emre Moa oder ein Alexander Isak, von dem man sich doch sehr, sehr viel erwartet hat. Und dann gibt es aber auch ein paar, die ich persönlich sehr enttäuschend finde. Also ich habe zum Beispiel Stunden –oder Stunden ist übertrieben –aber sehr oft mit Sascha über Thiago Maia geplaudert, der mich persönlich sehr beeindruckt hat und wie ich mich ganz stolz hingestellt habe und erzählt habe, dass aus dem mal ein ganz, ganz großer wird. Und der hat eigentlich bisher sehr, sehr schwache Leistungen nur abgerufen. Also es ist recht interessant bei Talenten, aber wir haben das auch bei der Guardian-Liste gesehen. Da sind immer wieder Spieler dabei, die absolut floppen und dann einige, die eigentlich die wenigsten am Radar hatten und die blühen dann auf. Und ich glaube, das macht auch diese Liste eigentlich immer wieder recht interessant. Weil es ja doch eigentlich Jugendliche sind, die doch erst Fuß fassen müssen.
Genau, wenn alles vorhersehbar wäre, bräuchte man ja letztlich auch so eine Liste nicht. Aber Maja hat so underperformed, dass er mir gerade nicht mal ein Klingelchen auslöst. Wo spielt denn der gerade? Hilf mir bitte kurz. Welche Position überhaupt?
Der spielt eigentlich so ziemlich alles im Mittelfeld. Er war Anfangs Spielmacher und ist jetzt im defensiven Mittelfeld bei Lille. Den wollte Marcelo Bielsa unbedingt holen. Nachdem der aber starke Anpassungsschwierigkeiten hatte –Maja, eigentlich Bielsa auch –ist der derzeit nicht mal auf der Bank vertreten in der Liga.
Dann haben wir jetzt eine halbwegs peinliche Wissenslücke bei mir gedeckt. Aber so ist das eben. Man kennt nicht alle. Also ein paar Namen aus der 2017. Liste, Musa Dembélé, Markus Reschford, Thiermo Werner, Julian Brandt, logischerweise Usman Dembélé, Mbappé, Coman, Pulisic, Leroy Sané, Asensio, Delhi Alli, Bentan Kour, Marco Grujic war da schon mit drauf mit 17 Jahren, Kai Havertz, Hernández, Denial, die Bayern umwerben, Jonathan Tartt. Das sind jetzt nun mal ein paar der Namen. Da seht ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da gibt es einige Spieler, wo man jetzt in der Rückschau sagen kann, auf jeden Fall, da hat es sich gelohnt, ein näheres Auge drauf zu werfen. Bei einigen war es schwerer vorherzusehen, bei anderen einfacher. Und wir wollen jetzt so ein bisschen der Frage nachgehen, Sascha, woher kommen denn aktuell die Toptalente im Weltfußball? Und weil ihr da so viel Zeit reingesteckt habt, seid ihr natürlich die perfekten Adressaten für so eine Frage. Sagen wir mal, welches Land ist gerade das, was die heißesten Talente hervorbringt?
Also in Frankreich springen aktuell die meisten Talente raus. In unserer Liste haben wir allein schon 19 Spieler vertreten, die nur aus Frankreich kommen. Was auf jeden Fall noch mal so diesen ganzen Trend der WM 2018 bestätigt. Auf jeden Fall, dass da noch viel nachkommen wird. Portugal ist auch sehr gut vertreten mit 12 Spielern in unserer Liste. Die natürlich auch aufgrund der EU-17 und EU-19-EM-Siege 2016 und 2018 einen ziemlich großen Pool an Spielern mitbringt. Und die Bundesliga ist mit 20 Spielern immerhin vertreten. 20 unserer Talente kommen aus der Bundesliga. Deutschland generell ist nicht ganz so gut vertreten.
Okay, also weit weniger als die Hälfte der Franzosen, die daraus kommen. Kann mir jemand von euch erklären, warum gerade französische Talente so begehrt sind? Liegt das vielleicht auch an unserem Fokus, den wir haben als Board-Liebhaber? Und wir sehen eben dann einen Weltmeister aus Frankreich. Wir sehen eben Portugal als das Land, das bei den Juniorenturnieren abgeräumt hat. Kommt das daher oder lässt sich das noch anders begründen? Jetzt mal eine offene Frage an denjenigen, der sich berufen fühlt, die zu beantworten.
Ich glaube mal, dass es generell so ist, dass in Frankreich viel mehr auf die Jugend gesetzt wird. Zum Beispiel in Deutschland in letzter Zeit. Das war vor ein paar Jahren, würde ich jetzt sagen, noch anders. Ich glaube einfach, dass mittlerweile auch die Konkurrenz einfach viel stärker ist. Früher war es halt so, dass vor ungefähr zehn Jahren Deutschland der Vorreiter war. Man hatte unzählige Jugendspieler wie einen Schweinsteiger, wie einen Podolski und viele weitere. Die Konkurrenz hat einfach nicht geschlafen. Man hat darauf reagiert und man sieht es einfach in Frankreich, die sowieso bereits gute Jugendspieler hatten. Jetzt aber noch mehr produzieren. Genauso das Gleiche passiert natürlich jetzt auch in Frankreich, Spanien sowieso. Und auch die Italiener haben zum Beispiel immer mehr Talente, wo man früher eigentlich immer gesagt hat, die sind zwar talentiert, aber sie sind halt noch immer quasi Altstars. Und das ist Startnetz später.
Wobei man natürlich sagen muss, ich habe mir gerade eben mal die Liste gezogen von über Transfermarkt. Die Bundesliga hat aktuell einen Durchschnittsalter von 25,5 Jahren. Mit einem Legionäranteil von 53 Prozent. Und die Ligue 1 ist ein bisschen älter mit 25,7 Jahren im Durchschnitt. Also ich würde jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen, dass in der Liga generell mehr junge Talente spielen. Nur hat man irgendwie das Gefühl, dass die Liga-Talente eher ins kalte Wasser geworfen werden als in Deutschland. Dass in Deutschland trotzdem immer noch eher der 26-Jährige, der 27-Jährige in der Stadt aufsteht anstelle eines 20-Jährigen.
Das fand ich generell ganz interessant. Diese Diskrepanz zwischen Herkunft von Talenten, die dann in eurer Liste gelandet sind, und der Liga, in der sie spielen. Wenn wir kurz bei der Herkunft bleiben, bevor wir über die Ligen sprechen. Die viel gerühmten Engländer, die gefühlt schon viel weiter sind in ihrer Nachwuchsentwicklung, haben von den 110 Plätzen bei euch nur 9 eingenommen. Henry, kannst du mir erklären, warum das so auseinandergeht? Also kommen die vielleicht erst noch? Sind die noch jünger? Und das wird eine zukünftige Entwicklung sein? Oder wie würdest du das begründen?
Also auch in England ist es so, dass die jungen Spieler bisher eben wenig Zeit bekommen bei den Top-Mannschaften. Das beste Beispiel dafür ist ja hier Hudson Odoi, der jetzt ja mit Bayern in Verbindung gebracht wird, der aber bisher bei Chelsea eigentlich kaum Einsatzzeit bekommen hat. Und erst seit es die Wechselgerüchte gibt, ja regelmäßig in die Kala berufen wird. Dafür zeigt sich dann an so Leuten wie Sancho, der in England zum Beispiel auch überhaupt keine Chance bekommen hat, der sich dann dafür aber bei Dortmund wirklich absolut und fragendlich gespielt hat, dass das Talent da durchaus vorhanden ist.
Gut, und das ist natürlich für euch, wenn ihr ja logischerweise müsst ihr ja irgendein Kriterium nehmen, um diesen Pool an allen Spielern einzugrenzen. Und wenn er dann über Einsatzminuten geht, dann fliegen die natürlich auch noch ein bisschen unter dem Radar. So könnte man das dann vielleicht auch begründen. Dann lass mal auf die Ligen gucken, das fand ich nämlich auch noch interessant. Tatsächlich, wenn man schaut, wo spielen die Talente, die ihr ausgesucht habt, dann ist auf Platz 1 die Bundesliga mit 20 von 110 Spielern. Liegt das vielleicht daran, dass ich hier auch mutmaßlich mit drei Menschen spreche, die die Bundesliga am intensivsten verfolgen?
Ich glaube, das ist einfach, weil es mit –ich würde mal behaupten –Dortmund, Hoffenheim und RB Leipzig und vermutlich auch demnächst mit den Bayern in letzter Zeit extrem viele Jugend-Transfers gab. Wenn ich gerade richtig denke, haben wir mit Alphonso Davies, Hudson O'Doy, Leonado Balea, die sind einfach unzählige Bundesligaspieler dabei und vor allem natürlich sehr beeindruckend RB Leipzig zum Beispiel, wo mit Upamecano und Konaté eigentlich zwei –Upamecano glaube ich ist gerade noch ein 1998er, also nicht in der Liste vertreten –mit Konaté ebenso einen unglaublich beeindruckenden jungen Spieler in der Innenverteidigung hat, die einfach sehr auf alle samt auf viele junge Spieler setzen und ich glaube einfach, dass die drei, vier Mannschaften da vielleicht noch diesen Tick Unterschied machen.
Ja, das ist eine gute Begründung. Wahrscheinlich auch Hertha BSC, die einen starken 99er-Jahrgang haben, aber das bringt uns ja schon auch so ein bisschen zu der Frage, wer sind denn so eure Favoriten? Wir können jetzt nicht alle 110 Spieler durchgehen, das ist vielleicht dann auch nicht das richtige Format dafür. Und die Leute sollen ja auch noch sich das in Ruhe mal bei euch auf dem Blog durchlesen. Sascha, fang mal an. Wen würdest du denn jetzt herausgreifen aus den 110, wo du sagst, über den sollten wir mal kurz ein Wort verlieren, denn aus dem könnte was werden.
Also ich muss sagen, das ist João Felix von Benfica. Der Spieler, der mich am meisten beeindruckt hat.
Sag mal kurz, die Position, auf der er spielt.
Er spielt linker Flügel, aber er kann eigentlich auch offensiv das Mittelfeld spielen. Oder ganz vorne allein im Sturm. Er ist einfach ein unfassbar guter Spieler. Er hat aktuell eine Torbeteiligungsrate von 58 Minuten. Er ist eine Torbeteiligung bei Benfica. Trifft auch immer in den Derbys gegen Sporting. Also wirklich ein unfassbarer Spieler. Er hat auch eine Ausschiegsklausel von 120 Millionen mittlerweile drin. Das ist sein Vertrag. Chelsea war angeblich auch schon dran. Angeblich sind auch die Bayern an ihm dran gewesen. Also diese hat es in der Urdeu gerüchter aufgenommen. Aber da wird Bayern vermutlich die Kürzeren ziehen. Er ist auf jeden Fall ein Spieler, den man auch überhalten sollte. Generell auch andere portugiesische Talente wie Rafael Leão von Lille. Auch unfassbar gut eigentlich. Er kommt auch über seine Kurzeinsätze vor allem in letzter Zeit. Aber vor allem zur Jahreswende hat er vier Spiele hintereinander getroffen. Also auch ein sehr interessanter Mann.
Das hört sich schon interessant an, vor allem die Portugiesen. Da haben wir ja schon häufiger gute Stürmer und Offensivkräfte gesehen, die aus Portugal kommen. Henry, wer waren denn so deine persönlichen Favoriten in der Liste?
Also ich frage mich dann mal ganz langweilig und bleibe dabei Matisse Licht, der inzwischen auch schon quasi ein gestandener Spieler ist, der damals bei Ajax, ich glaube, mit 16 oder 17 reingeworfen wurde und bei dem nach drei oder vier Spielen eigentlich schon sich die Frage stellt, zu welchem Topf allen wird er nachher wechseln, bringt für sein Alter wirklich alles mit, sehr, sehr konstant, körperlich sehr stark, gute Endgeschwindigkeit, souveräner Spielaufbau und generell die ganzen Ajax-Spieler, sowie auch Justin Kluivert, der leider zum AS Rom gewechselt ist.
Warum leider?
Weil ich ihn lieber weiter bei Ajax gesehen hätte. Bei dem AS Rom kommt er bisher auch nicht auf so viele Einsatzzeiten. Auch wenn sich das jetzt ein bisschen gesteigert hat. Es war ein großes Wechseltheater damals mit ihm, hat sich da wohl auch nicht ganz optimal verhalten.
Vor diesem Wechseln. Generell ist Ajax die Schmiede für Talente. Sie hat ja auch gute Traditionen, gehört ja zur Vereinsphilosophie dazu. Marco, täuscht der Eindruck, dass die aktuell wieder sehr viele Talente in ihren Reihen haben. Delikt haben wir ja gerade schon genannt. Frankie de Jong wurde genug berichtet, wechselt zu Barca jetzt zur neuen Saison hin. Haben die gerade wieder eine besonders gute Generation oder beschränkt sich es dann auch schon auf die zwei, drei Namen, die man da nennen kann?
Nein, auf keinen Fall. Ajax hat eigentlich seit drei, vier Jahren produziert, bringen die unglaublich viele Spieler heraus. Und das Unglaubliche ist, dass sie jetzt bereits eine junge Generation haben, wo die Leute sagen, in ein, zwei Jahren sind die wirklich, wirklich gut. Aber genauso eben wie zum Beispiel ein Spieler, den wir aufgrund seines zu jungen Alters wieder nicht reingenommen haben, ist Ryan Gravenberg, der mit 16 Jahren, glaube ich, bereits in der Eredelisie zum Einsatz kam. Ebenfalls ein unglaublicher Spieler, der professionell auftritt, bereits spielt, als hätte er jahrelange Erfahrung. Also da kommt wieder Unglaubliches nach. Bei Ajax macht man wirklich, wirklich sehr viel richtig. Scouten auch sehr gut. Kaufen derzeit wieder von unterschiedlichen Vereinen. Sehr, sehr junge Spieler. Ich glaube, vor einer Woche haben sie einen Spieler gekauft, den wir am Radar hatten. Von Nordseeland zum Beispiel, der ist für 3 Millionen Euro gewechselt. Den sagt man jetzt nach, dass er vielleicht sogar besser als Ödegard sein könnte. Also es ist wirklich unverstellbar.
Welcher Ödegard? Der, der uns versprochen wurde oder der, den wir gesehen haben?
Der, der versprochen wurde, obwohl der, den es derzeit gibt, gar nicht so schlecht ist, würde ich mal behaupten. Aber er wird vielleicht nicht an die Erwartungen anknüpfen, behaupte ich jetzt mal.
Gut, die Erwartungen waren ja auch mit Reha Madrid und FC Bayern dann auch sehr, sehr hoch an diesen sehr jungen Spieler. Wen hast du denn sonst noch so auf dem Zettel Marco, wo du sagst, da lohnt es sich jetzt noch ein paar Worte drüber zu verlieren?
Ich würde mal sagen, einer meiner Lieblingsspieler oder ein Spieler, bei dem ich sehr darauf hoffe, dass er bald den Durchbruch schafft, und zwar ist das der Name –ich hoffe, ich kann ihn jetzt richtig aussprechen –Dominik Szoboszlaj, ein Ungar, und zwar er spielt beim FC Liefering in der Jugendmannschaft von Red Bull Salzburg und war bereits mit 16 Jahren Stammspieler in der 2. österreichischen Liga und hat seit seinem Debüt unglaubliche 0,64 Scorer-Punkte pro Spiel. Und das mit nur 17 Jahren und mit einem unglaublichen Auftreten mit Standards, die schon Ninho stolz machen würden und einer Schusstechnik, die einfach sprachlos macht.
Und wenn ich da jetzt sage, naja, er ist auch nur 2. österreichische Liga, was hältst du mir entgegen?
Dass es seit zwei Tagen Gerüchte gibt, dass die Bayern ihn unbedingt holen wollen. Und eigentlich knapp ganz Europa dran ist an dem zentralen Mittelfeldspieler. Also ein wirklich sehr, sehr guter Spieler. Und ich erwarte mir von dem eigentlich sehr, sehr Großes. Aber ich bin gespannt, ob er in Salzburg bleibt oder bei den Bayern.
Ich meine, generell sind natürlich Gerüchte, gerade bei diesen Jugendspielern, immer etwas Besonderes, finde ich. Weil zum einen wissen wir ja, alle Gerüchte werden auch gerne mal gestreut. Sehr, sehr gerne auch von den Beratern. Also ein Jugendspieler, der 17 ist und halbwegs den beitreten kann. Und da haben nur nicht drei internationale Top-Clubs angefragt. Den gibt es eigentlich da draußen nicht. Und auf der anderen Seite ist es ja mit den Gerüchten so, dass sie auch deswegen so gerne genommen werden von uns Fußballfans, weil man bei diesen jungen Spielern immer alles an Träumen und Wünschen, was man hat, reinprojizieren kann. Also jeder Spieler ist ja potenziell der nächste Messi oder der nächste Cristiano Ronaldo oder der nächste, auf welcher Position er auch immer spielt. Und niemand kann dem widersprechen, weil man in der Regel bis auf YouTube Highlight-Clips und so weiter kaum etwas von denen sieht. Und es könnte halt immer richtig sein. Deswegen reden wir vielleicht auch besonders gerne über diese Jugendspieler.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall. Also man fängt halt immer ein bisschen zum Träumen an. Man hofft halt. Und manchmal kommt halt dann auch der emotionale Part. Aber ich glaube, das ist halt eher bei uns, weil wir uns halt mit den Spielern so viel beschäftigen. Oder halt mit diesen Spielern so viel beschäftigt haben. Dass man dann einfach auch ein bisschen halt darauf wirklich hofft. Und nur darauf wartet eigentlich, dass der Spieler endlich den Durchbruch schafft. Aber es hat ja auch, finde ich, etwas, wenn man dann sieht, dass es ein Spieler nicht geschafft hat. Ging jetzt natürlich gemein, muss man sagen. Aber es ist einfach, finde ich, interessant zu sehen, wie viele in den Himmel gehoben werden. Also ich denke da zum Beispiel an einen Embry-Mohr, wie vorher genannt, der dann im Endeffekt, würde ich mal behaupten, gerade noch so im Mittelmaß des Fußballs ist, des Europäischen. Weil er eigentlich sehr gute Anlagen mitgebracht hat.
Das kann man so sagen. Also am Ball konnte er doch einiges physisch und dann vielleicht auch manchmal mental. War das dann nochmal eine andere Nummer. Wen habt ihr denn noch so auf der Liste? Sascha, du durftest schon länger nichts mehr sagen. Gibt es noch welche, die du gerne vorstellen würdest, hier in dieser Runde?
Wo wir gerade von Emre Mohr sprechen. Es gibt tatsächlich in unserer Liste einen Spieler, der Emre Mohr zum verwechselnden Ähnlichen sieht als Spielertyp. Das ist Abdul Qatir Bülmür von Trabzonsbo. Wenn man nicht weiß, dass das unterschiedliche Spieler sind, kann man noch denken, dass es derselbe Spieler ist. Genau wie Emre Mohr ist er auch rechtes Mittelfeld, links fußt, zieht gerne innen, dribbelt gerne, schießt gerne. Sie sehen sich ähnlich zum Verwechseln. Bei ihm hoffe ich tatsächlich auch, dass er, anders als Emre Mohr, sich eher auf Fußball konzentriert und diese ganzen Nebenschauplätze kleiner lässt als Mohr. Dass er hoffentlich auch den Durchbruch schafft, spätestens im Sommer dann auch irgendwann wechselt, was der Tokaiweg ist, soll ja angeblich schon Gerüchte gegeben haben, um einen Wechsel nach Liverpool. Aber ich denke auch, dass er auf jeden Fall zu früh kommen würde. Einer der coolsten Spieler war, Marco, den nennst du, glaube ich, Kjell Scherpen aus Holland. Torhüter, 2,04 Meter groß oder so. Von der Statue her ein bisschen wie Jan Oblak von Atletico. Allerdings manchmal ein wenig tollpatschig. Also riesengroß, hat einen super Reichweite, aber manchmal, wenn wir etwas tollpatschig mehr rauslaufen, fäll ich manchmal auf seine eigenen Füße. Aber trotzdem irgendwie Top-Anlagen. Kjell Scherpen ist 19 Jahre alt aktuell. Und wo spielt er gerade?
Marco, da spielt bei …Beim FCM, also eigentlich ein Verein, die man sich überhaupt nicht in der Liste erwartet.
Allerdings, ja. Kjell Scherpen, 2,04 Meter. Na gut, mit 19 kann man auch nochmal ein bisschen unbeholfen sein bei dieser Größe. Kristallisieren sich denn da bestimmte Positionen raus, auf denen Talent besonders häufig zu sehen ist? Ist euch das aufgefallen beim Zusammenstellen der Liste? Also bei welchen Positionen war es besonders schwierig, sich zu einigen?
Also ich würde erstmal gerne damit anfangen, dass gerade in der Innenverteidigung –ich habe es nicht nachgezählt, aber es sind mindestens fünf oder sechs Franzosen. Also die Innenverteidigung in Frankreich ist auf Jahre Varan gesetzt, wenn man noch bedenkt, dass da gerade Varan und Umtiti Stamm spielen. Und auch allein in der Bundesliga sind es glaube ich drei oder vier Innenverteidiger, die alle unter 20 sind und alle Franzosen sind und alle Stamm spielen.
Ja, das ist natürlich auch schon –das haben wir auch schon mal im Rasenfunk thematisiert. Mit Nia Katté, DIALO, mit Ndika hat man da allein schon drei, wo man sagen kann absolutes Bundesliganiveau, wenn nicht sogar vielleicht darüber hinaus. Und alle drei aus Frankreich, das ist natürlich ein interessanter Punkt. Gab es sonst noch irgendwie Positionen, die besonders diskussionswürdig waren, Marco?
Ich würde fast sagen, das wären die offensiven Free-Win-Spieler gewesen, also die linkes Mittelfeld und das rechte Mittelfeld.
Tatsächlich, die, wo man immer sagte, so schwierig jemanden zu finden.
Genau, ich glaube, das liegt aber auch einfach daran, weil gerade im jungen Alter, wo einfach noch nicht diese Physik so notwendig ist bzw. noch nicht so konkurrenzfähig ist, reicht es irrsinnig oft einfach auch schnell, um eine starke Technik zu haben. Was natürlich auch im Fußball, im Profifußball reicht. Aber halt natürlich ein bisschen ein Unterschied ist, ob man jetzt auf einen 16-Jährigen trifft oder auf einen gestandenen Sergio Ramos vielleicht. Und es ist halt schade, man darf halt auch nicht vergessen, die 110 sind halt auch nur eine Auswahl der unserer Meinung 110 besten, aber es sind halt trotzdem, je nach Position, halt leider wirklich Spieler weg, die einem sehr wehtun. Also mir zum Beispiel am Flügel, da haben wir wirklich lang herum diskutiert, ein Schapi Suleymanov vom Carasnotar, der in der UEFA Youth League in der vorigen Saison unglaublich viele Tore geschossen hat. Und da ist halt einfach dann die Frage, ist er nur in der Jugend so gut? Reicht es da, dass er dann auch Stammspieler ist? Da gibt es halt extrem große Diskrepanzen halt noch immer.
Ist es da einfacher, Offensivspieler zu bewerten, weil man Tore und Vorlagen als klar dokumentierte Messlatte für Leistung hat als zum Beispiel Verteidiger?
Ja, ich denke, dass man auch gerade bei Verteidigern, wenn man sich Spiele anguckt oder auch einzelne Clips anguckt, dass man da auch schon gute Ansätze sehen kann. Also man kann schon sehr wohl sehen, ob ein Verteidiger ein gutes Traumgefühl hat im Zurückwärtslaufen oder ob er ein gutes Gefühl für seine Langpässe für Spielverlagerungen hat. Also ich würde nicht sagen, dass Offensivspieler leichter zu bewerten sind.
Aber findet man denn auch Clips zu jedem Spieler? Gab es auch Spieler, die für euch quasi nur Name und Statistiken geblieben sind, auch Nachrecherche?
Also für mich war ganz am Anfang Sepp Sandenberg damals noch 16 Jahre alt und den Verteidiger seit Zwolle, in Miederlande, war für mich ein sehr ungeschriebenes Blatt. Und dann habe ich auch wirklich einige Wochen damit verbracht, mir illegale Livestreams reinzuziehen, um dann ihn halt spielen zu sehen. Und kann aber auch nachher sagen, es hat sich gelohnt.
Das ist doch gut. So ein bisschen habt ihr ja so eine Scouting-Arbeit dann auch gemacht. Gab es irgendwann auch mal Kontakt zu Scouts? Das wäre höchst interessant, mal eure Eindrücke mit denjenigen abzugleichen, die das hauptberuflich machen.
Wir haben vorigen Sommer mal eine Anfrage bekommen aus der israelischen Profi-Liga. Sascha, weißt du noch, was das für ein Verein war?
Das war Maccabi Petac. Ich weiß nicht, ich bin das Israelisch nicht ganz so mächtig. Aber die haben uns auf jeden Fall angefragt damals, ob wir denn nicht für sie die Scouting-Arbeit übernehmen könnten oder zumindest in den Spielern nennen können, die sie verpflichten können. Also das gab es auch alles schon bei uns.
Und da habt ihr gesagt, die Liste erscheint im Februar. Rufen sie dann nochmal an. Und übrigens, das macht 10.000 Euro.
Ich glaube, wir haben damals, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, eine Liste geschickt aus 3. Liga-Spielern und österreichischer Bundesliga-Spieler. Und wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, haben die sogar bei einem Spieler von der Admirer, Admirer war kein Mödling, damals angeklopft, aber haben dann keine Einigung erzielt. Aber es waren ganz komische E-Mails. Also eine recht eigenartige Scouting-Arbeit.
Aber haben sich denn auch mal andere Leute bei euch gemeldet? Also wir wissen ja alle, wenn das neue FIFA rauskommt, dann beschweren sich alle, die sich zu schlecht bewertet sehen. Oder wenn man mal bei Instagram auch nur ein bisschen durch die Jugendabteilung der Profivereine durchscrollt, dann sieht man sehr schnell, dass im Grunde jeder Jugendspieler heutzutage da aktiv ist und dass die meisten auch sehr kommunikationsfreudig sind. Fast schon ein bisschen zu kommunikationsfreudig. Vielleicht bin ich aber auch da auch einfach schon zu alt für mit meinen 33 Jahren. Aber haben sich denn da auch mal junge Talente selbst bei euch gemeldet? Gab es da schon Kontaktpunkte oder Reaktionen auf eure Auswahl?
Wir hatten vor kurzer Zeit, als wir die Treute hochgeladen haben, wo auch unter anderem Bayern-Treuter Christian Früchtl mit dabei war, haben wir auf einmal ziemlich viele Likes auf Instagram von Christian Früchtl Fanpages bekommen. Allerdings haben sich noch keine Schüler bei uns gemeldet. Noch nicht.
Ist ja auch noch nicht alles online. Ich vermute mal, ihr habt noch ein paar weitere Favoriten auf der Liste. Werft mir noch ein paar Namen an den Kopf, die ich dann schnell nebenher googeln muss, während ihr mir sagt, warum die so gut sind.
Henry? Ich nenne Kiek Pierie. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich ihn richtig ausspreche. Er ist ein niederländischer Innenverteidiger, 18 Jahre alt, spielt beim SC Heerenveen und ist wahnsinnig spielstark. Er durchbricht die Verteidigung immer wieder. Ob er jetzt etwas angespressen ist, geht natürlich immer wieder, ob mit Dribblings oder mit ein paar Spielen. Er bringt auch dekensiv einiges mit und geht jetzt in seine zweite Saison bereits. Ich hoffe, dass er da bald auch wegkommt. Ich hoffe, dass ich seinen Spielertyp einer sehr großen Mannschaft durchsetzen kann, weil er für mich so gewissermaßen den Fußball der Zukunft verkörpert.
Das musst du mir jetzt noch ein bisschen näher erklären, weil er seine Position als Innenverteidiger so offensiv auslegt? Oder wie meinst du das?
Ja, ähnlich wie bei Frenkie de Jong auch. Er nutzt immer wieder das andere. Selbst unter Druck stehen löst er spielerisch die Situation und versucht immer, die beste Lösung zu finden. Das ist für mich gewissermaßen modern. Es zeigt, dass er wenig Angst vor Fehlern hat und die spielerische Lösung über allem steht. In Zeiten, in denen das Pressing immer stärker und intensiver wird, sind auch Innenverteidiger immer weiter gefragt, ob sie den Ball selbst mehr als ordentlich nach vorne treiben können.
Wenn er gleichzeitig noch verteidigen kann, dann ist das natürlich perfekt. Er ist auch Kapitän der niederländischen U19, was ich natürlich nicht wusste, bevor ich ihn jetzt mal nachgeschlagen habe. So möchte ich jetzt auch nicht hier mit Wissen rumprallen, das ich nicht habe. Wen hast du denn noch auf der Liste, Henry?
Rikki Puik ist noch ein Liebling von mir. Ich habe mich daher bei jedem Barca-Spieler bei uns in der Liste gefreut. Das Problem bisher ist, dass er bei Werbe die Barca-Spieler recht wenig einbindet. Man ist als Barca-Fan, kann man schon sagen, wenn das er von einem Talent viel hält, wenn er das überhaupt mal in Kader beruft. Aber die Spiele von Puik waren sehr vielversprechend. Am Ball unheimlich stark. Der Spielaufbau kann er sich gut beteiligen, kann aber auch sehr kreativ vom Tor werden. Auf jedem Drittel des Spielfelds absolut überragend mit Ball. Der Ball bewegt sich sehr stark und bringt fast alles mit, um im Barca-Mettelfeld in einigen Jahren bestehen zu können.
Und es ist vermutlich auch ein Eigengewächs aus La Masia.
Richtig.
Das hört sich vielversprechend an. Jeder darf jetzt seine Liste leer machen nacheinander.
Mir fällt jetzt noch ein, passend zu Barca. Und zwar den Brasilianer Emerson. Ein Spieler, der glaube ich bei Transfermarkten noch immer erst auf der vierten Seite zu finden ist. Weil er einfach noch einen Marktwert von nur 50.000 hat. Der ist aber am letzten Transfertag für 12 Millionen zu Barca gewechselt. Und ist derzeit an Real Betis verliehen. Das Interessante bei ihm ist aber, er ist ein Spieler, der die Statur von, ich würde mal behaupten, Sol Campbell hat. Ein riesiger Körper, extrem breit, aber unglaublich laufstark ist. Also eine Mischung aus Sol Campbell und Dani Alves. Und ich glaube auch, wenn der auf einen Gegner zuläuft, ich glaube, dass man da echt Respekt bekommt, muss ich sagen. Und genauso spielt er auch. Der springt von 10 Metern Entfernung im vollen Lauf mit der Kretsche voraus und das Beindruckende ist, er schafft es, jedes Mal den Ball zu spielen. Und wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, war er auch einer der Außenverteidiger mit der höchsten beackerten Distanz pro Spiel. Und das hat anscheinend Barca so fasziniert, dass die ihn eben jetzt für 12 Millionen verpflichtet haben. Also ich bin da echt gespannt. Ich glaube, dass sie dieses Mal –ich meine, sie haben jetzt schon viele Außenverteidiger geholt, von denen man erhofft hat, dass die demnächst mal kommen könnten. Aber ich glaube, dass sie diesmal wirklich einen guten Spieler geholt haben.
Das ist tatsächlich einigermaßen skuri, wenn man auf den Kader von Real Betis geht und dann sieht man zwischen all den Marktwerten im Millionenbereich hast du da auf einmal diesen 50.000er. Und das ist dann Amazon. Das ist tatsächlich was Besonderes. Wen hast du noch auf der Liste, Marco, über den du gerne noch kurz sprechen wollen würdest?
Ich würde eigentlich sagen, Diogo Dalot. Der ist im Sommer zu Manchester United gewechselt. Eigentlich muss ich sagen, ich habe mir schon erwartet, dass er ab und zu mal eine Chance bekommt. Aber ich würde jetzt mal behaupten, hätte er nicht so mit einer Verletzung zu kämpfen gehabt, würde er sogar noch öfter spielen. Weil der ist jetzt nämlich unter Solskjaer sogar Stammspieler.
Also ist er ein rechter Verteidiger, der vom FC Porto dorthin gewechselt ist.
Genau, und sehr variabel ist er. Er spielt auch auf der linken Seite, das ist ebenso fehlerfrei. Und ein wirklich technisch sehr solider Spieler, kommt halt aus der Jugend von Porto. Und ich hätte mir bei dem ehrlich gesagt nie gedacht, dass er sich doch noch, oder doch so rasch eigentlich, in England dann durchsetzt. Und das ebenso gar trotz seiner Verletzung.
Du hast es mit den rechten Verteidigern, was? Das ist ja auch nicht schlimm. Das rechte Verteidiger sind ein ragesätes Gut. Gibt es noch jemanden, über den du sprechen möchtest?
Interessant ist, es ist generell. Ich habe mir da eine kleine Liste aufgeschrieben. Und zwar ich finde auch interessant. Wie gesagt, es ist ja nur eine Auswahl, die 110. Aber es sind zum Beispiel, wir hatten viele Spieler von Nordseeland dabei und da gibt es zum Beispiel ein Mitglied Damsgaard, der erst 18 ist. Das ganze Mittelfeld ist bei Nordseeland extrem jung. Ich glaube, das ganze Mittelfeld ist zwischen 17 und 18 Jahren alt. Ich habe da mal einen Vergleich aufgeschrieben. Die vorige Stammelf war 22,4 Jahre alt. Zum Vergleich einmal Dortmund. Die vorige Stammelf war 25,2 Jahre alt. Also ganze drei Jahre älter. Es hat zwar leider bei uns keiner in die letzte Auswahl geschafft, also unter die letzten zehn Positionen jeweils. Aber ich finde es eigentlich recht interessant, dass da mittlerweile wirklich unglaublich viele Nationen auf junge Spieler setzen. Für mich waren am beeindruckendsten Portugal und Dänemark. Da ist auch zum Beispiel Benfica mit unglaublichen Spielern vertreten. Ein Florentino zum Beispiel oder auch ein Chota, der am Wochenende sogar sein Debüt gefeiert hat. Und bei der U19 EM Torschützenkönig wurde. Ein wirklich ebenfalls sehr starker Spieler. Ein klassischer, ich würde sagen, der fällt so in diese Reihe von Joao Felix, den Sascha vorher erwähnt hat. Auch ein offensiv Allrounder, sehr schnell, starke Technik. Ja, einen mörderischen Abschluss hat eine tolle Übersicht. Ein extrem kompletter Spieler eigentlich.
Es macht so Spaß, über Talente zu reden. Ich kenne hier ein von fünf Namen, vielleicht mal irgendwie so nebenhergehört, aber in meinem Kopf sind das jetzt alles die besten Spieler der Welt. Und ich denke mir, okay, ich möchte sofort das Mainverein, alle davon kaufen. Es macht einfach Spaß, dieses Thema. Sascha, hast du noch welche offen auf deiner Liste?
Ich würde an dieser Stelle nochmal eine Lanze für die Linksozialiker brechen. Ich habe gar keinen erwähnt hier. Nicolas Cossa von Montpellier ist eher so dieser klassische Außenverteidiger. Also am ehesten vielleicht zu vergleichen mit Marcel Schmelzer. Im Vorwärtsgang eher so behäbig, aber defensiv sehr grillig, sehr giftig. Gewinnt viele Zweicamper, sehr aufmerksam gegen Pressing. Und interessanterweise war sein Großvater damals der allererste Kapitän von Montpellier. Das nur so am Rande. Auch noch ein ziemlich cooler Spieler, der mich manchmal sehr frustriert, weil er doch der Wechsel auf die Leistungen zeigt, ist Moussa Sylla von Monaco, mit dem ja aktuell alles drunter und drunter geht.
Da ist gerade diese Woche ein Kurzpass zu erschienen. Da haben wir unter anderem auch über Monaco gesprochen. Und welche Rolle kann er denn da spielen im tollen Haus Monaco unter Jetzt-Wieder-Chardin?
Seit Chardin wieder da ist, hat er gar nicht mal gespielt. War auch gar nicht ein Kader. Aber zuvor war er halt einer der wenigen konstant in Monaco. Wenn man bedenkt, dass Monaco allein in der Champions League diese Saison 28 Spieler eingesetzt hat. Da war Sylla schon einer von denen, die öfter gespielt haben. Er erinnert mich immer so ein bisschen an Antrel Di Maria mit seiner Tripling-Fähigkeiten und auch der Art und Weise, wie er den Ball führt, wie er den Ball am Gegner vorbei legt. Und auch sein Zug zum Tor. Aber er macht immer noch so viele Fehler. Aber ich denke trotzdem, wenn Monaco dieses Jahr doch abschrecken sollte, sollten einige Europa League-Vereine oder kleinere Champions League-Vereine auf ihn werfen. Weil er trotzdem ein ziemlich guter Spieler mit sehr viel Entwicklungspotenzial ist.
Es ist halt auch schwierig, wenn du Mittelstürmer bist und in einem Team mit Falcao spielst und dann der Trainer zurückkommt nach Henri, der eben erstmal wieder auf die Alten setzen möchte. Dann haben es viele schwer. Benjamin Henrichs spielt ja auch nicht mehr, seitdem er wieder zurückgekehrt ist. Das nur zur Einordnung. Gibt es noch einen weiteren Namen, den du uns auf die Ohren legen möchtest?
Florentino Luis, ebenfalls beim Benfica. Ist wahrscheinlich eher so ein Typ Javi Martinez. Sehr unauffälliger Spieler, hat er am Wochenende sein Debüt gegeben. Hat 28 Minuten gespielt, beim 10 zu 0 gegen National. Also 10 zu 0 in der ersten portugiesischen Liga, wohlgemerkt. Hat das 28 Minuten gespielt und hat dort gleich mal in der kurzen Zeit die meisten Tacklings, also sechs an der Zahl, vollführt. Mehr als jeder andere auf dem ganzen Feld. Und begann in nur 28 Minuten.
Ja gut, beim 10 zu 0 haben sich die meisten gedacht, warum geht der Jungspund da jetzt eigentlich noch so rein. Ich weiß, was du sagen willst. Okay, das waren viele interessante Namen. Gibt es noch jemanden, der bei irgendjemanden von euch drei noch erwähnt werden soll, das ist jetzt eure letzte Chance, bevor wir dann die Hörerinnen und Hörer auf eure Seite schicken, um sich die ganze Liste anzugucken.
Ich meine sicher, es gibt noch unzählige natürlich.
Klar, aber ich habe euch ja auch gebeten, euch auf Kurzpass einzuschränken. Ein Tribümgespräch war nicht drin zu dem Thema.
Einen Spieler hätte ich wohl noch.
Ja, Henry, leg los.
Das ist der erzeugte Barco. Denkmal den Vornamen habe ich auch wieder falsch ausgesprochen. Auf den bin ich aufmerksam geworden, weil er einen sehr eigenartigen Weg gegangen ist. Er hat bei Independiente gespielt, ist Argentinier, offensiver Mittelfeldspieler, aber kann auch ohne Qualitätsverlust auf beiden Flügeln spielen und ist jetzt 2018 in die USA gewechselt, zu Atlanta United. Ein Weg, der mir erstmal doch irgendwie recht eigenartig erschien, weil er bei Independiente schon auf sich aufmerksam gemacht hatte und es auch die Gerüchte gab, dass er zu einem der größten europäischen Clubs geht und er sich dann dazu entschieden hat, in den USA zu spielen.
Ja, tatsächlich interessant. Aber ich habe ja mit dem Leiter der Nachwuchsakademie von Atlanta United mit Toni Ennen einen Kurzpass aufgenommen. Da hat er auch erwähnt, dass eben diese Spieler gerade aus dem südamerikanischen und mittelamerikanischen Raum, für die ist die MLS nochmal auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise attraktiv, weil sie zum einen sehen, dass man durchaus den Sprung schaffen kann, von der MLS in die europäischen Top-Ligen. Da gibt es jetzt immer mehr Beispiele. Und zum anderen ist eben die Fanbase mit entsprechendem Migrationshintergrund relativ groß. Und man ist dann quasi auch eine Nummer, wenn man in die MLS wechselt. Das könnte das vielleicht, was er mir da erklärt hat, ein bisschen bestätigen, diese besondere Fußballerbiografie. Ihr seid sehr höfliche Gäste. Ich würde sagen, alles andere sollen sich die Hörerinnen und Hörer selbst anlesen. Denn wir konnten ja jetzt logischerweise nur einen Bruchteil der Arbeit hier repräsentieren, die ihr euch gemacht habt. Habt auf kawanisfriseur.de zusammengeschrieben. Und so wie Cavani und so wie der Friseur könnt ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, die ganze 110er-Liste sehen. Da sind noch nicht alle Teile veröffentlicht, aber das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich Marco in den nächsten Tagen alles passieren. Wunderbar. Dann danke ich euch dreien sehr, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Super interessantes Projekt. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich glaube, wir sollten auch häufiger nochmal in welchen Konstellationen auch immer über Talente sprechen. Man sieht, dass ihr da sehr tief drin seid. Ich danke euch in der Reihenfolge des Auftretens. Sascha Felter, et Sascha Fültrer auf Twitter. Danke dir, Sascha. Danke dir, Marco. Marco Stein, et Marco Stein, unterstrich CF. Danke, Marco. Und Grüße, ein Lasergruß an den Ad Laser Pass. Henry Hiener, am Telefon zugeschaltet. Danke dir, Henry. Ich hoffe, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, diese etwas besondere Kurzpass-Folge hat euch Freude bereitet. Geht auf kawanigsfriseur.de. Und vielleicht hören wir ja von dem einen oder anderen Spieler, über den wir heute gesprochen haben, nochmal etwas. Es würde mich wundern, wenn es nicht so wäre. Und dann können wir alle sagen, also wir Hörerinnen und ich, wir können sagen, wir haben es zuerst im Rasenfunk gehört. Und ihr drei könnt sagen, ja, wir haben das damals bei unserem 110er-Projekt, haben wir den Namen zum ersten Mal gehört. Habt eine gute Zeit, alle miteinander.